i
en rusia las protestas por la
encarcelación de navalny han provocado
ya más de 1400 detenidos en los últimos
días familiares y amigos se han
concentrado cerca de los centros de
detención donde se encuentran estas
personas arrestadas para intentar
facilitarles comida y abrigo pero moscú
sigue resistiendo las presiones también
las de la unión europea que se ha
interesado por el estado de nabai y ha
criticado la ausencia de una
investigación pero moscú no está
dispuesta a permitir que le den sermones
desde bruselas o desde washington así lo
ha explicado el gobierno ruso en varias
ocasiones que durante las últimas horas
ha dirigido incluso mensajes muy claros
a los gobiernos occidentales diciéndoles
que es hora de que se empiecen a
preocupar por sus propios asuntos y no
insistan más sobre el caso naval ni
a
[Música]
desde el departamento de estado yo bailé
en dijo que alexéi navalni tiene que ser
liberado del encarcelamiento
políticamente motivado del que está
siendo víctima al presidente ballén
aseguró también que a pesar de los
esfuerzos que se están haciendo en
términos diplomáticos con moscú ve con
mucha preocupación los esfuerzos rusos
de suprimir la libertad de expresión y
de manifestarse de forma pacífica según
by the naval ya ha sido atacado por
denunciar la corrupción en rusia y
debería ser liberado inmediatamente y
sin condiciones por su parte el
secretario de estado- anthony blinken le
ha pedido también al gobierno ruso de
putin que libere inmediatamente a
navalny ya los cientos de ciudadanos
rusos que fueron detenidos ilegalmente
tras ejercer su derecho a manifestarse
[Música]
tras la condena de tres años y medio de
prisión a alexéi navalni a manuel ama
con reaccionó en su cuenta de twitter
diciendo que el respeto de los derechos
humanos y como de la libertad
democrática no son negociables el
mandatario ha mantenido una diálogo
estratégico con moscú y lo ha hecho
participe en la gestión de las
diferentes crisis mundiales de los
últimos años pero parece que esto no ha
dado fruto y ahora francia pues ha
decidido subir el tono de voz en contra
de moscú fue el secretario de estado de
asuntos europeos el que dijo que para
ejercer una verdadera presión sobre
moscú hay que detener el proyecto nord
stream 2 usted gasoducto que se está
construyendo entre alemania y rusia un
proyecto muy importante a nivel
económico pero sobre todo a nivel
geopolítico para moscú de hecho francia
pues ya ha hecho la petición a berlín
pero lo cierto es que angela merkel
hasta ahora ha dicho que el proyecto
continúa en pie lo que sí es seguro es
que francia va a poner sobre la mesa la
discusión de las sanciones a rusia en el
próximo consejo europeo
[Música]